i was drinking
you were drinking pretty heavily
were you there
as the courtroom battle between johnny
depp and amber heard rages on johnny's
ex jennifer gray is entering the chat
claiming that the oscar nominee was
crazy jealous and paranoid when they
were together
let me get you up to speed
the 62 year old dirty dancing star
started dating johnny back in 1989
and according to the independent in her
new memoir out of the corner out tuesday
the actress writes the now 58 year old
actor proposed to her within two weeks
of meeting but things quickly went south
as johnny commuted back and forth from
vancouver getting into alleged fights in
bars and skirmishes with cops quote he'd
started missing his flights home to la
having overslept or when he did come
home he'd be crazy jealous and paranoid
about what i'd been up to while he was
gone people have said that to me they
said you know now that you're in this
position you gotta
you know watch what you do i guess huh
but
i don't really
i don't really want to do that because
if i do that then i'm being dishonest to
myself and besides being dishonest to
myself i'm being dishonest to the people
who are watching
you know i'm going to do what i do and
hopefully people can accept that
like i said i'm not out to prove that
i'm
the messiah or something
jennifer says she attributed johnny's
ill-temper and unhappiness to him
feeling miserable and powerless to get
off the tv show he was starring in at
the time 21 jump street
look i've been to jail three times it's
no big deal
what the hell told you anyhow
was common knowledge there's a weird
thing you know people work their whole
lives and they say oh i'm gonna do
everything and everything i can to be
famous and then when once you get famous
you do everything you can so you can
stay out of the public eye
so uh there's there's a line in there
somewhere that i think everybody's sort
of missed
i think i missed it
and jennifer she says she broke off
their engagement just before her 29th
birthday after he left for a meeting and
didn't come back or contact her for
several hours
e.t has reached out to johnny's reps for
comment
back in 1988 eti was with the actor on
the set of the cop drama where he opened
up about the pressures of being famous i
do miss privacy it's a little strange
it's a little strange to go out to a
restaurant or something
and have people sort of you know
gawking at you like like you're some
sort of uh
i don't know like an animal on display
or some sort of you know freak it's a
little strange
to get used to
i don't know if if things continue to
happen for me and
hopefully they will
hopefully i'll get used to it you know
of course now johnny is very much in the
public eye as his defamation suit
against his ex-wife amber hurd continues
to make headlines you only sued the
author
of this article amber heard correct
which seems she was the one making the
statements yes i
had the opportunity to fight back johnny
who testified last week is suing amber
for 50 million dollars in response to an
op-ed the 36-year-old actress wrote for
the washington post in december 2018
about being the victim of domestic
violence he claims the op-ed cost him
his career and is looking to prove that
her claims are untrue mr depp how did
you feel when you learned that
you were being dropped from the pirates
of the caribbean franchise
i didn't quite understand
how
that after that long relationship and
quite a successful
relationship certainly for disney
um
that
they would
that suddenly i was
guilty until proven innocent meanwhile
amber is expected to take the stand this
week